beeindruckend gigantisch
er habe auf großer fahrt quer durchs
land unterwegs von mehr so mehr
wir sind an der meistbefahrenen
künstlichen wasserstraße der welt
schiffe schiffe und nochmal schiffe der
nord ostsee kanal ein highway für ozean
er ist wasserstraße wirtschaftsfaktor
und ausflugsziele in ein
[Musik]
von da bis da 100 kilometer schön
komplett
acht stunden dauert die kanal passage in
rendsburg werden die großen nun
kleineren köppel mit allen ehren
empfangen
ich sag's erstmal herzlich willkommen am
schönsten platz in schleswig holstein
und ich habe gleich ein richtig schönes
großes schiff für sie in grün gehalten
die heinrich ehlen containerfrachter
diese schiffe kommen aus der tiefsee
häfen und schilder die die container zum
beispiel in diesem fall nachgeht
da kommt jetzt die handliche her und das
liegt in schweden und die geht nach
hamburg hat immer gesagt sind die
schiffs begrüßungs anlage eine
touristische attraktion und die welt von
wolfgang martens einer von sieben
schiffs begrüßen am kanal
wir sind an einer der meistbefahrenen
künstlichen wasserstraße der welt keinen
anderen kanal gibt der stamm etwas mit
kommt das ist also nicht der panamakanal
und auch nicht der suezkanal wir sind
hier sehr und du sitzt nur hier bei uns
so nahe dran am nord ostsee kanal über
schiffe weiß wolfgang martens einfach
alles länge breite tiefgang die
motorleistung und die
höchstgeschwindigkeit alles vermerkt auf
4.000 karteikarten wie die eigentlich
jeder hier das ist ja schon mal ein
schiff zum hingucken die dass man sagen
kann da lohnt sich das mal den leuten zu
sagen das sind das ist eine langsam
läufer ist eben durch den erheblichen
tiefgang mit 90 61
die hymne des heimatlandes hier die
portugiesische und das winken gehirn
dazu seine faszination
[Musik]
ja ja
ich finde sogar wieder aufregend und
jedes mal wenn das schiff von den durch
papst freue ich mich auch notwendig
ja
die heinrich ela eines von 30.000
schiffen die jedes jahr den kanal
passieren auf dem weg zwischen nord und
ostsee
[Musik]
trotz gps und satellitengestützter chefs
ordnung und egal ob marinetanker
containerschiff oder kreuzfahrer wenn es
eng wird muss eine hanns ruder der die
strecke kennt ein mensch ein lotse
[Musik]
martin berg kennt hier jeden zentimeter
unzählige schiffe hat er schon sicher
durch die enge wasserstraße geleitet für
ihn ein traum tab lotse an sich ist
eigentlich für ehemalige seeleute die
zur see gefahren sind und lange von
ihren familien und von zuhause getrennt
gewesen sind ist das immer ein traumjob
wenn sie ihren wenn sie ihre tätigkeit
weiter ausüben können also war der an
bord von schiffen sind aber regelmäßig
zu hause
langweilig ist der job nicht doch
momentan herrscht flaute
gruner der niedrige ölpreis der um weg
um die spitze dänemarks momentan
attraktiver für die räder
im moment ist wenig los also wir haben
so ein verkehrsrückgang 35% kompletter
wegfall der kreuzschifffahrt und das
aber auf allen deutschen revieren wenn
nord ostsee kanal kommt immer noch dazu
dass bei nachlassender wirtschaftlicher
aktivität die energie preise sinken aber
das bedeutet dass die abkürzung strecke
unattraktiv wird weil es günstiger ist
außen rumzufahren bei vollgas
es geht auf schafften
anhalten ist nicht fliegender wechsel
bei voller fahrt
wir dürfen nicht mit drauf zu riskant
die angst vor dem virus grassiert auch
unter seeleuten
[Musik]
große fette noch größere seefahrer
träume der duft der weiten welt mal eine
andere vertritt der nord-ostsee-kanal
knapp 100 kilometer lang teilt der
schleswig holsteiner in einen nord und
einen süd hälfte die reise zwischen den
meeren lohnt sich nicht nur für schiffe
sondern auch für schiffs liebhaber
[Musik]
ein minimum an ausrüstung reicht
klappstuhl und foto
[Musik]
schiffe schauen die natur genießen auf
den 100 kilometern entlang des kanals
gibt es viel sonne auf zwei oder vier
rädern
mit dem boot zu fuß der kanal heute
nicht nur wirtschaftsfaktor sondern auch
ein beliebtes ausflugsziel
[Musik]
wenn die schiffe vorbei ziehen das ist
dann also irgendwie ganz großes kino
ja es wunderschön natur pur man fühlt
sich wenn man aus einer großstadt kommt
als hätte man oropax in den ohren bei
dem wetter traumhaft und ich hoffe doch
mal rein springen zu können
klein westerland heißt die einzige
offizielle badestelle an der
internationalen schifffahrt straße
schwimmen planschen mit aussicht
badevergnügen hatten die erbauer des
kanals vor genau 125 jahren allerdings
nicht im sinn die kriegsflotte sollte
unbehelligt zwischen nord und ostsee
verkehren können so wollte es kaiser
wilhelm der zweite
[Applaus]
das projekt das bauwerk so spektakulär
wie einschneidend für land und leute
im wahrsten sinne des wortes der kanal
cup wege trennt ganze dörfer und steht
zehn brücken zwei tunnel und 14
die entlang des kanals übersetzen
verbinden ein geteiltes land dafür
bietet er außergewöhnliche perspektiven
für die kapitäne auf dem wasser aber
auch für die seeleute an land von da bis
da 100 kilometer schön komplett man
steht überall stellen die schönen sind
ist egal welcher übergang das ist egal
welche fähre egal welche brücke ob man
hier einkehrt oder ob man in serie steht
der ganze kanal ist eigentlich
beidseitig bevölkert und ist eigentlich
alles schön
uns gefällt die landschaft die weiße
landschaft und die schiffe das
technische bauwerk das war für mich
natürlich entscheiden das hat mich
interessieren
[Musik]
technik die begeistert obwohl in die
jahre gekommen
die schleusen die herzklappen des kanals
von hier aus wird jedes schiff gesteuert
und geordnet zumindest die großen
[Musik]
spannend aber nicht ungefährlich für die
kleinen
der kanal auch sein revier gastwirt und
kanal fischer hans bauer den
containerriesen tankern und königlichen
megayachten hat er mit seiner nussschale
nur wenig entgegenzusetzen
seit generationen leben er und seine
familie am und vom kanal mit dem tag als
ich aus der schule gekommen und vorher
war ich immer mit also das war das war
schon eine gemeinheit wenn man alleine
losgefahren ist zum fischen und ich
durfte nicht mit oder ich muss den
schularbeiten machen
das war nicht so gerade mein großes ding
und dann habe ich also praktisch seit
ich zehn war war ich immer mit auf dem
wasser hier stellt er seine netze auf
hier fängt der hering und plastisch was
er nach hause bringt ist nicht mehr so
viel wie früher
mit den jahren ist es immer schwieriger
geworden davon zu leben und deshalb
haben wir auch irgendwann mal auf
herings fest umgestellt oder gastronomie
und serien wohnung weil das immer
schwieriger wurde
rein vom fischfang zu leben fisch satt
frisch aus dem kanal das wasser übrigens
hat badesee qualität
den kanal auf oder entlang des wassers
genießen es geht aber auch anders
dann steigen wir mal nach oben folgen
sie mir unauffällig für uns geht es
jetzt hin auf 178 stufen um genau zu
sein am kanal steht eine der
bedeutendsten und größten brücken
europas auf 51 stahl feier zweieinhalb
kilometer lang erstreckt sich die
rendsburger eisenbahnhochbrücke über den
kanal technisches wunderwerk und
industriedenkmal
ein tolles rennen wenn jetzt gleich noch
ein paar ski bekommen wir natürlich soll
die eiserne lady wie sie auch genannt
wird eine attraktion die jedem
internationalen vergleich standhält
zu ihrer zeit war die brücke das größte
stahlwerk der welt keine einwände
meistens kommen denn von den besuchern
einwände visa und was ist mit dem
eiffelturm
tja der eiffelturm ist zwar höher aber
hier wurden 18.000 tonnen stahl
verarbeitet und der eiffelturm hat er
nur gut 10.000 tonnen stahl ganz oben
angekommen auf 42 metern bietet sich den
besuchern ein spektakulärer blick auf
die wasserstraße aufregend also das ist
schon die höhe und diese perspektive man
sieht die brücke aber nur von unten auch
von weiten und wenn man in rendsburg
denkt denkt man ja gleich an die brücke
aber wenn man es erstmal hier oben drauf
ist krieg man noch mal ein ganz anderes
gefühl
gerade wenn man von hunden guckt ist das
ja sehr filigran und man denkt immer wie
kann so ein höheres gewicht auf so
wenigen punkten stehen und hier oben ist
einfach nur schön herrlich unsere
lebensader hier in schleswig holstein
vor einen seite trennt ist uns natürlich
alle anderen seite bringt uns auch alle
wieder zusammen
also am wetter hier oben das ist
natürlich einmalig der kriegt man noch
mal wieder ganz andere sicht auf seine
heimat das ist schon toll
[Musik]
kleine schiffe
große kater
der nord-ostsee-kanal ein stück fernweh
mitten im binnenland